NATO.
You’ve probably heard of it.
It stands for the North Atlantic Treaty Organization.
And guess what?
It just turned 70!
But what does it do?
And do we still need it?
Let’s take a look.
In the aftermath of World War II, North American and Western European countries banded together against Soviet aggression.
They formed NATO, a political and military
alliance “founded on the principles of democracy,
individual liberty and the rule of law.”
NATO’s goal is to promote stability and
trust among Western democracies.
Its central idea is collective defense.
This means an armed attack against one NATO
country is considered an attack against them all.
But after the Cold War, NATO’s heavy focus
on Russia changed.
The group welcomed in new members, many from
the former Soviet bloc.
It expanded its global role: launching peacekeeping
missions in places like the former Yugoslavia,
Afghanistan, and Libya.
Today, NATO faces a new set of political and
organizational challenges.
At the top of the list are rising tensions
between Russia and the West.
After the fall of the Soviet Union, these
tensions had faded.
But more recently, however, Russia modernized
its military, invaded its neighbors, and meddled
in European and U.S. elections.
In response, NATO has ramped up military exercises
and opened command centers close to Russia’s
borders in Estonia, Latvia, Lithuania, and
Poland.
It's also launched a new cyber command to fight
growing threats from Russia and elsewhere.
Yet NATO appears weakened by internal divisions.
Rising nationalism and even a move toward
authoritarianism in member states like Turkey,
Hungary, and Poland are undermining the founding
principles of the alliance.
As is the United States.
NATO's most powerful member is now deeply
critical of the organization.
President Donald Trump is no fan of multilateral
organizations in general.
And for NATO in particular, he has repeatedly blamed other members for not paying their fair share.
On this, he has a point.
Every NATO country has pledged to spend
2 percent of its GDP on defense.
Yet, out of its 29 members, only 9 countries do so.
On the other side of the argument are NATO
supporters.
They believe the alliance still plays a vital
role in the 21st century.
After 9/11, NATO countries
came to America’s defense.
They joined the war in Afghanistan, fighting
and dying alongside U.S. soldiers.
In fact, this was the only time in NATO’s
history that allies employed that collective
defense at the heart of the treaty.
Looking to the future, NATO can be a potent force against terrorism, cybercrime, and Russian aggression.
Sure, NATO may need updates.
But its presence is vital to ensure that the
United States doesn’t have to face these threats alone.